this year's Los Angeles Auto Show as
always is a showcase for American brands
like Cadillac and GMC here you'll see
huge cruisers and brawny pickups with
plenty of power under the hood just what
Americans like best
[Music]
some of the best known examples are the
RAM truck and the Lincoln Navigator
[Music]
but other renowned manufacturers are
showing off their latest models in LA to
[Music]
her CBC M she had Tobias MERS points out
California is the u.s. as biggest car
market la is one of the most significant
automobile shows in America and deadly
flattened head of marketing for Porsche
says his company loves la love affair
here's how Porsche presents its new
dynamic duo the 718 Boxster GTS and the
718 Cayman GTS are the top models in
their ranges complain who says that
despite all the talk about connectivity
and digitalization many customers want
something pure unfiltered and analog one
of us police teachers vessel Zetas it is
concealed Tamiya analog Porsche wants to
cater to those desires with the new 911
Carrera T luring the purists are its
reduced weight manual transmission and
mechanical rear differential lock
meanwhile Toyota has a new version of
the Camry this compact mid-range sedan
has been around since 1983 and although
it is a top seller in much of the world
it's not on offer in Europe
[Music]
Toyota's luxury car division Lexus is
drawing attention with the new edition
of its RX 350 l customers had clamored
for a third row of seats and here Lexus
has provided it mercedes-benz has
brought several highlights to Los
Angeles first the s-class convertible
the open four seater is the lap of
luxury and profits from the developments
in the hardtop s-class models
highlight number two is the third
generation of the CLS
[Music]
that's kind Percy these chief designer
Gordon Wagoner says everything is new in
the third generation of the CLS which
created a design icon and a new class of
four-door coupe A's this is the first
time that a car has been permitted to
look like a design sketch the way
designers draw them the enthusiasts with
a small roof and an exaggeratedly flat
silhouette that makes this car
spectacular all teams are spectacular
the CE OS is being released with a
completely new selection of three
six-cylinder engines two diesels and a
gasoline
[Music]
proceeded ezm cheese project one is
heading in an entirely different
direction
versus the one displays all the
technologies that is currently feasible
its 1.6 liter v6 engine was adopted from
a Formula One race car for electric
motors give this speedster more power a
total of seven hundred forty five
kilowatts allow it to reach speeds above
350 kilometers an hour
[Music]
not quite that fast but still very
sporty is Chevrolet's classic Corvette
but the tradeshow offers more than
concept cars and mass-produced vehicles
here you can also see one-of-a-kind
creations like this Kia stinger souped
up by the tuning pros at West Coast
Customs and here's a concept snowmobile
based on a GMC pickup truck it has a
rack for snowboards and it's chains
allow it to tackle the mountains
[Music]
if you want a really eccentric an
extravagant ride try this to seat three
wheel buggy it's sure to catch eyes and
turn heads